okay welcome to this video playing Kevin
king from Spain going for them caro-kann
check yeah this line has soft me quite
well in recent blitz games c3 is some
probably the best line for white 25 is a
decent reply though who came I want to
prevent Nigel form you understand a form
yeah the Sun makes a strange strange
impression at least then from my taste
but not quite sure how to how to play
though I don't want to take on f4d for
that much is clear yeah c'mon let's just
develop a piece it's not so clear how he
wants to develop his his pieces now you
mean the night is clogging up the whole
position and once you move it I can take
on the default form yes you can do that
but quite shortly this again this issue
how to how to continue I can even place
you five it's not it's not ridiculous
but not helping much admittedly not even
Bishop d6s a move well why not just
develop you cannot castle long anyway
because a2 is hanging all the time
yeah problem just ok I would see for
wait wait wait wait he is intending see
form I must attend to that ok let's just
grab it should be our ok we should be 4i
just more this one just have ruger rook
e8 look g8 yep just ripped Jean ok now
after taking here I actually am he has
got all night to a fire okay so check
that sound let's do it do it this way
what's the sum should be quite solid
there's always this weakness on g3 if i
take here he's going to play a rope 2 h8
I don't want that so probably just get
the King out first
this Bishop is nicely positioned just
let's just take that get the palm back
threatening ji tun and I think I really
ticket
if he goes g3 f9f 624 something like
that it should be it should be alright
okay so just grab it or not yeah let's
grab the point the simplest simple
solution and now maybe here attacking
the rook and intending to take on c4
play 93
yeah so 93 would at least secure draw is
there some way to play more viciously
maybe I can take on c4 yeah we'll get
five now what else yeah that is that is
some else smooth surprisingly don't
really understand why check he goes into
the South pin with regret coming
so now he's into a pin
huh yeah Sonny
Roxy 7
yeah yeah what what does silly silly
moti
check really funny okay the question is
my pro am I playing this too hard for
when check it so it's always always a
bit tricky Jack I need to do oh it's
giving me this Bishop as well
so on how to win this now but probably
get the King over so that it helps
against the pawns don't try to provoke
some some weaknesses cm10 xe5 now check
yeah so I get at the pawn or making play
passive moves okay this should be good
now controlling controlling the position
now so one probably here to go gay one
check check check time warner how to
actually win now okay let's uh to see
three is a good idea
yeah how to win now is also matter of
time of course it's not a problem if you
have like it like two minutes check the
other Scots mated rugae one made
checkmate wow this Bishop g3 move really
was a shocker he had this this move okay
but I have exactly exactly yes this line
to to win problem oops sorry about that
check until you need to play a root g7
bag yeah and this is some it's an
exchange but still a little bit tricky I
can go here yeah this is good I can I
protect the seventh-ranked make sure no
pones get lost yeah but what I didn't
understand really why why did he not
play a rook air-five this is just
nothing happening here this is a simple
move go here you take a seven and you're
okay and yeah this is not not really
doing anything I mean no no threat or
anything let's say I go here can you can
just move the king it's it's just a draw
yeah maybe he can he really a plant that
and it's not working out maybe possible
okay thanks for watching